you know sometimes it's best to just sit
back and enjoy the show and as we
approach season four of you tonight
we're taking a look at everything you
need to know before the fan favorite
Thriller makes its Twisted return
heartbreak is always a catalyst for A
New Path You're a murderer Joe you're
wrong about me I want to prove it to you
he is back yes Joe Goldberg played by
Penn Badgley returns in you season four
and wow viewers last Saw Joe head to
Paris in pursuit of his librarian flame
Marianne Joe is now living in London
where he hopes to leave his escapades
and murders behind with his new persona
as Professor Jonathan Moore Professor
Jonathan Moore
why are you here she killed someone oh
did someone break your heart but Joe
appears to creep back into his obsessive
ways with a new love interest the only
difference this time there's a new
killer and Joe's the one being stalked
police are continuing to investigate a
second murder among the elite
the Culligan to Eat the Rich killer
this season also sees a slew of new
faces among them Adam a rich kid Gambler
and Nightclub owner played by the white
lotus's Lucas Gage he's still my
Spotlight and I murder you
Kate Joe's newest love Obsession played
by ghosts actress Charlotte Ritchie and
Lady Phoebe a socialite played by
EastEnders star Tilly keeper season 4
will unfold over 10 episodes and will be
split into two parts with the first half
launching on February 9th and the second
one month later
I couldn't get away